你已經是富邦證券的客戶了嗎?
這支影片我們帶您用五分鐘完成受信開戶四合一的線上申請。
一次整合信用交易、不限用途借貸、證證借貸與雙項借貸四大業務。
以上業務都在同一個申請入口,可以依據您的情況申請所需的受信業務。
開戶前準備。
申請開始之前,請先準備好您的身份證、證反面與第二證件、健保卡或駕照。
並依據申請業務規定準備彩利證明
並且確定您已具備中華民國稅級身份
就可以開始申請咯
如果來不及觀看的朋友
也可以隨時按暫停跟隨影片的步驟哦
讓我們一起進入開戶申請流程吧
步驟一 進入開戶鏈接
首先請先登入富邦AI Pro
點選衣櫃臺中的寄有庫加開
再點選新用戶 無限用途 借款 借卷 出借
即可進入申請流程
步驟二 身份驗證
請輸入您的身份證字號與生日
接著完成OTP驗證與電子交易密碼驗證
就能順利登入申請系統
步驟三 選擇申請項目
在這一步請勾選受信開戶
並依據你的需求選擇要申請信用交易
股票出借 補信用途借貸
證券業務借貸 雙項借券
確認後請點選下一步
選擇開戶分公司
這一步請留意
受信相關業務僅限同個分公司辦理
步驟四
上傳證件及填寫開戶資料與內部人聲明
一畫面指示上傳身份證正反面及第二證件
完成後點選確認上傳
接著填寫基本資料與職業資訊
如果申請項目包含不限用途借貸
雙項借卷或警派出借
系統會請您進行內部人身份資訊確認
步驟五
填寫申請額度與財力資料提供
這個步驟會依據您的需求填寫各項授信申請額度
並請您提供財力證明資料
您可以選擇臺股庫存資料
自行上傳財力證明檔案
例如他行財力、不動產等
或帶入臺北富邦銀行的均額
請注意,此功能需以開通網銀
步驟六,簽署契約
最後一步,請您依據您申請的授信項目
逐一相約並勾選相關契約內容
簽署完成後,即可送出開戶申請
步驟七 查詢審核進度
送出申請後 只要重新登入申辦入口
就能隨時查詢審核進度
如果系統顯示需補件 請點選立即補件
依照畫面指示補齊或修正資料後送出
即可完成補件的流程咯
好啦 是不是發現受信開戶很簡單
現在就動動手指把賬戶開起來吧
如果在操作過程中有任何的疑問
歡迎查詢您所屬的營業員
最後記得訂閱按贊
並把影片分享給那個
永遠都在說明天再開戶的朋友
那我們下次再見
拜拜